hey guys this is Gregory and this is
Jung Gary
well rejects we wanted to talk a little
bit about something you know during a
little segment of ours called how it
could work I think it was the creator of
the purge was doing an interview and
he's talking about I think in a couple
of interviews about how he in how he
thinks the Persian be a cool television
series and before he did that interview
I was telling John that I think it would
be a really cool TV series so it was
pretty ironic that around the same time
he said dude I wanted to give just my
little idea of how I think it could work
I don't like have specific characters or
plot points in mine I just have a
concept for how I think the show could
be handled I think what a lot of people
will probably do will probably might
consider is the purge is 12 hours and so
a lot of you'll probably imagine a 12
episode season where each episode is
like one hour to be great if it took
place in real time on Netflix and so you
don't have commercial breaks or some
kind of cable show where you don't like
a full-on hour yeah like a full hour 9
minute it's not like 24 where it's only
really 45 minutes yeah what I think
would be cool will be a better touch to
it is instead of just doing 12 hours 1
hour like I think you do the 12 hours
you keep in a real time but I think the
first episode of the season should be
before the purge is happening before we
hop in a real time because it would
allow us to really set up that cuz
that's part of what makes the movies
effective is the set up leading up to
the purge so I think the first episode
it would be great if that was all the
character setup of what's gonna lead and
what's gonna have the purge happen
what's gonna happen with the purge what
I would like to see from this season is
like of the show if it works like one
thing I love about American Horror Story
is that how they constantly switch up
the horror genre every season and I know
they like change the whole cast and
everything but it would be cool to see
them take have a specific kind of horror
genre per season as well because you
know like the first
I haven't seen election years in Sabina
honest I haven't seen election year but
the first purge was a home invasion
thriller in Bayesian thriller second one
I don't know the word for oh really like
out on the streets and actually seen the
purge happening yeah yeah really violent
yeah so it said it so I feel like every
season it doesn't have to fall if they
if they have multiple seasons in mind it
is not the fall the same characters
every season maybe you bring like a
couple if you want to but I think it'd
be cool if you went to different parts
of America in different parts of the
world that also have the purge going on
that way you can explore a whole new set
of characters every single season but
they're all within the same you know
purge universe kind of like how the
movies are working Frank grill doesn't
part area but it does seem like each one
is it look at a specific situation on
purge night
yeah specific yeah exactly or my other
idea that I thought could work for it is
if every episode is just one hour long
that covers a different person yeah a
different person in the purge we're
thinking on a similarly there are a
couple ways that you could do this and
you could you can cross both of those
you could yeah you could check back in
every few episodes you know how to carry
like a walking dead yet goes from
sometimes it has they focus on these
characters or then they focus on these
characters and other season yeah like
there are episodes where you just don't
see Rick yeah like they could use
something like that where it's like
sometimes the whole cast is the other
some episodes are not or it could be
something where it's just exploring a
completely different new story like a
Twilight Zone all within the same purge
universe yeah well I think the purge has
a lot of potential to be mined as a TV
show cuz there's a lot of stuff you can
cram into it you know and I know a lot
of people see the movies and that some
people want even more of a sort of
fleshed out political subtext and that
is something that you could definitely
sustain over the course of the show or
you could on the flip side if you wanted
to go in a more episodic route you could
make it where you could explore
different ideas within the purchase get
a little more fluid with the tone and
the style you know X and other elements
and genres you don't always have to be
carnage in the streets necessarily but I
think you could work yeah in both of
those ways I there's an episodic like
each one
kind of like a twilight zone of crime
like a different person
or you could do that sort of we pick a
few characters that we start to get to
know and then we follow them for a while
and kind of check in and out actually I
did come up once with a that could be a
purge story what I imagined because I
forgot the stat is that they they say in
the movies of how much crime has gone
down and how like there's like what like
only a few little small percentage of
crime that actually occurs throughout
the year yes a crime drops like 90
percent yeah I can never say it correct
so I thought like okay that's small
percentage of crime is there a criminal
boss that's happening that that has some
kind of organization operating with
within the time when the purge is not
happening and he really profits on the
night of the purge in some way like I
felt like there's still crime going on
so what if there was like some type of
criminal like yeah do people people pull
off organized operations during the
purge as well
yeah or is it just primal so so I
thought of a story where there is a
criminal who they know is like they just
can't pin anything like one of those
guys yeah where they know he's the bad
guy
we just can't spot him we can't pinpoint
anything on them we don't have enough
evidence so like a secret group is
tasked the Suicide Squad crash fast and
furiously yeah yeah I'd stop every movie
can become fast in the period we have it
everywhere Austin a war movie yeah
constantly change know what I thought it
would cool they liked ask a secret force
to go find him find this person and kill
him and on the perch because it's
illegal for them to have this task force
operate together so they are kind of
like a Suicide Squad in a way where it's
like their mission has to be secretive
it's illegal but what they can't find
any evidence to pinpoint on to depend on
this guy so they have to they have to
take advantage of the 12 hours of the
Persian but that I didn't kill him and
do illegal things or
to uncover who he really is oh they want
to kill ya they want to uncover who ya
there and they wanna they want to get
rid of him because they feel like he's
like a big Lincoln to how the crime
still operates in America okay so he's
the villain of the year when the purge
is not having a really good reason that
they waited until now but yeah the law
has to stay within the law in order to
go after criminals yeah so they're gonna
out of New Jersey
so yeah they're gonna have their NATO
jurors like someone I don't know Frank
Rolo gets blow the team or some shits on
the team and they're on this team is
doing something illegal to kill this guy
but they're using the pur just as the
night to actually go and and do it
because that's the one night they could
get away with it yeah yeah they're
pulling some kind of intense job on
purge night that involves killing so
instead of watching good guys trying to
survive 12 hours you're watching bad
guys trying to do bad things to better
yeah not an evil man it's the night of
you see me is a good place to explore
the darkness yes you know a lot of us
watch it late at night in the dark
that's just one concept I mean that's
the cool thing about a purge show or
where you couldn't you could have so
many different kinds of stories going on
and don't have to work so much within
these I constantly feel even with the
purge anarchy I really liked it I really
liked that movie a lot actually I still
felt that there could have been more to
explore that's the thing with the purge
though is that because it's a movie you
need to have the horror the action you
have it needs to be an exploitation
movie yeah some bigger ideas in mind
yeah but then you come back constantly
and then based off what a lot people say
in an election year I still feel like
they hold back on what they really can
achieve and I feel like a show is the
perfect playground for something like
the purge Lois I'm with the way how
horror plays on TV now with American
Horror Story and The Walking Dead I
think like a purge show would [ __ ] do
awesome you could just make it the
walking dead of human cruelty yeah
pretty much just like new groups of
interesting colorful people and
exploring different sides of that and I
and I think what works about a TV show
again is the purge gives us a view on
everybody or at least tries to so you
see the people at the bottom of the the
social ladder the people
and then the politicians who gained the
whole thing and then run it and that's
the cool chance that's where you could
almost get like black mirror with it
like really make some crazy political
allegory so like maybe the episodes flip
and tone that way almost like this
episodes like violent house of cards now
this like and one thing too is that
because the purge is a studio horror
film studio a horror tends to be the
weakest when it comes to violence in
films when I watch American Horror Story
and if anyone has heard anything about
the latest episode of The Walking Dead
you know that shows gang goes so
disturbingly violent they go really
violent I feel like the purchase is a
playground that calls for something like
I don't think they've skimped on that I
haven't seen anything in the pursue you
movie like like like it's it's mostly
footed by two indie independent studios
and then they have universals push for
the distro but like I don't know I've
seen every episode of American let's see
most of American or surf scene The
Walking Dead and the violence on there
completely outweighs anything I've ever
seen and I just saw the purge
election-year trailer in the theaters
just the trailer and I was seeing
they're going this is I was a little
unsettled I was like this violence cuz
it's all realistic it's all just people
in costumes being terrible to each other
like that violence I was like that's
pretty disturbing that's like a that's a
little more grungy and a little more
exploitation film than I think a big
studio horror movie whatever yet that's
okay work you're talking in terms of the
of what playground the purge movies are
currently under the umbrella that
they're currently under we have I'd be
like on a show they would like you this
is a chance to really showcase like
serial killers at the most extreme
Shuhei people like do we have more room
to do that yeah I think the movies do
ghetto at least a little extreme but you
could definitely a more extreme on TV
yeah and that's weird just TVs and DVD
lousy to go way more violent
well cuz there's no confusion if you buy
if you if you're a TV station you're
like we're
gonna make the purge it's like you know
there are things I've seen in American
Horror Story that have almost made me
throw up yeah how like disturbed it's
like a like a Saw movie like let the
last few Saw movies and I feel like the
purge is violent for sure not sitting
there saying like it's not a violent
film and it's not at times it's
disturbing but it while it can be
sadistic with its characters I feel like
that's a great it would be a great show
to show sadistic with its characters and
the violence all at once where I feel
like the violence would really add to
the specific movie oh yeah as well yeah
yeah because you get more space to to
learn about characters and and to feel
out motivations because search is a
great world to explore I think the
concept they like and everyone heard the
concept everyone want to shut up about
it
yeah you heard about this review or
crime is legal it's like and then people
debated oh whatever dude I don't think
it would ever happen but imagine if it
did like that's a cool ass concept yeah
so it lends itself really well to an
exploit yeah movie but it also lends
itself to a pretty interesting TV yeah I
think for a TV show it's it you could
explore the political themes you could
explore the psychological themes you can
explore so much more than just
exploitation and violence you that's
when the show that's when the story and
the concept can really come to a
brand-new medium a new high gear level
is when you have the time of a show to
do that if you make it a characteristic
because because the movies all kind of
thrive I guess on the same kind of
tension is oh god like yeah are they
gonna make it through the night to do X
Y Z like like this second in the third
movie they have you know further goals
than just survival but still it's can
they survive whereas if you did a TV
show you could have a different question
than just candidates I know and I feel
like there's other room for other kinds
of you know sick activities to occur I
don't want to like go into like big
detail right now oh you can get
literally invented there let's taste
what most of purge is is primarily you
know just you know like like blood
violence there's other murders there's
other forms of disturbing things that
you can use your imagination hot that
you won't
seen the purge movies but I feel like
you can go that [ __ ] batshit crazy on
a show though you would have to yeah
like that's that's the thing that I
think is a great idea about a purge show
and also a very worrisome idea because
I'm like you better have some great
writers because if you're gonna explore
enough that kind of [ __ ] yeah cuz yeah
thing is the movies you mostly explore
people's urge to kill each other yeah
and there are lots of crimes and lots of
other terrible it can be Morton they can
be just as damaging yeah and you can't
explore those on a show I don't think
that's territory that shouldn't be
touched but I feel like that is you're
gonna have to really make sure you
handle that the right way yeah like Rob
Zombie can stab an interesting episode
of liability for us ami get a purge
batshit insane
I would definitely see Rob Zombie that's
like the why be like yes please go and
make these all kick some characters I'll
give a [ __ ] cuz the exists I'm Rob
Zombie purge movie would be [ __ ]
intense and amazing because it's this is
it's the one it's the one excuse for
like something like Rob Zombie to come
in and go yeah here's all my [ __ ]
sick thoughts on paper for you guys you
can apply that just so many others yeah
you could you could really go batshit
with the style anthology because I get
different directors you could do Eli
Roth's the purge would yeah like a bunch
exactly you know douchey college kids
going on their heads night or you could
do you know that's a pigeonhole I don't
wear but you could do like a VHS style
one yeah yeah yeah like you could do
just about anything you could do one of
those episodes where it's like we're
gonna focus on this one lone purger who
always goes out he's always gonna be
okay but not this time
yeah you know like that solitary like
it's only one character the whole time
pretty much like you could do so many
cool yeah it would be cool to have like
yeah I think either one of the concepts
somehow combining them of yeah yeah it
would totally be [ __ ] awesome you
could either do or every few episodes
you throw in a vignette or every few
episodes you just throw in an unrelated
story yeah like you break away from the
main serial plots and then you do a an
episodic one wait
before it could still be going within
like the next like from 2:00 to 3:00
p.m. over over time to purge occurs yeah
like this is from 4 to 6 4 to 5 p.m.
again if you really constructed this
like really crafted this you could
almost have like a nice woven thing of
both intertwined storylines that will
ultimately hit each other or ultimately
I'll conclude but then you can also
explore tangents yeah so you can have
you know like a side quest here and
there I can have it be still worth the
shows while you could get a little more
experimental with how you're telling
this story and do a little more
character study stuff because really
what the purge would be is just the
study of that day I feel like what it
does to people I feel like taking each
episode and put it because 12 hours is
perfect for a show because it more every
Epis every hour of it will be so [ __ ]
like it would be a great excuse to have
like one episode works as primarily you
know this is Walt and Jesse talking
about chasing the fly yeah one hour in
the bird like not every hour has to be
the most intense [ __ ] hour yeah I
hope they do it I feel like they're
probably gonna be able to be able to do
it seems like and I hope if they do it
they they go with basic things or I hope
they go with a cable network that does
not have commercial breaks and I hope
that because I would also allow for
violence as well and I hope that they
have it take place within real time I
would go more for that instead of like a
completely separate purge yeah story
yeah it would be cool is like it it
takes every episode takes place within
the same day of that purge but every
hours focus on a different group not a
little too much that well you could just
do that and cut back and forth between
feet I want some kind of real time I
want us to feel like we're spending the
12 hours in the purge like if I binge
watch this like I think this would be a
great Netflix show like you release all
13 episodes on Netflix
it would research has been watching you
know you make the first episode an hour
and a half and you make it the hour and
a half before the purge starts in the
next twelve or all the real time of the
purge yeah that would be cool now you
make it they're cool maybe make the last
one like an hour and 10 just so you can
see what happens after but yeah I know I
I think
first episode ending the purge Google
commence in five four three two black
instead of music over the credits it's
just the syuri fade in just chaos that
would make me want to watch the birds
like they bother the final opening of
everything leading up to this [ __ ]
intense well and that's the thing is
this could be a really cool opportunity
because this could be the time this
could be the first let's say a movie to
directly just transition smoothly into a
show it's not like we're digging
something up and making it a show which
which works or you know awkwardly
divergent English oh yeah do new walk
yeah we're
yeah it's like the purge movies have
been successful there they're clearly at
least in terms of viability they have
lament 'm and this could be a cool
chance to actually go you know what we
might be able to make this even better
on a different format and we're gonna do
that i think you know so I hope this
works and I feel like it it very much
good yeah so a salute your purge movies
if you want dude combination universe
every now and again somebody makes a
reference to Frank Grillo but just a
little one yeah that's what like the big
green guy the thing that happened with
the senator the incident in New York the
grill Owens the gorilla woods got one on
that carry I'm making MCU references
yeah yeah but just tree like that yeah
just do that but in the MCU world yeah
Hawkeye could have a whole episode
because you know hot guy goes I'm
version for the weekend not having what
to do these goes out for targets right
my long shoots bad people in person
oh my god dude see that's the thing is
the purge is such a great positive you
want to see what every world yes like
under those circumstances
yes Batman goes on wastes so many
phenomena get rid of all my rogue
gallery tonight or at least all the
cities that would be a cool show that's
why there are other movie characters are
calling for character in the purge
that's why crime has dropped so much and
that's a whole side story we haven't
explored is because superheroes have
just killed drop after every person
likes huge numbers that's why they've
dropped that's why bad that's why
Superman feels so weird in those new
movies he's like you know I've killed
and what is it all for all right guys
that's how we think the purge show could
work if your nuke does good episode that
was a good episode if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe it day become
a reject join us John is the social
media manager at facebook.com slash the
real rejects the Facebook / blum blum
house does the purge yeah with platinum
dude talk to them John the social media
manager has the most ultimate power if
I'm not mistaken yeah I am the top of
the food chain because Facebook is the
future office employees Jason Blum